subscription beauty boxes are like goody
bags for adults if at alamdar is eagerly
unpacking a luxury box for around 50
euros she receives 628 beauty products
from various manufacturers she has no
idea what's in the box before she opens
it but curious customers can consult a
website to see the selection of products
currently available
the box and Hammonds on piston bus phone
violence it's like Christmas in the
middle of the year depending on your
subscription you receive surprise
parcels several times a year that's
what's cool about it the anticipation
the excitement and it's so nicely
wrapped it's the perfect occasional gift
to yourself introduced in the US back in
2010 Birchbox was the original Beauty
subscription package now many companies
offer such subscriptions including some
in Germany customers generally receive a
surprise package once a month they can
note their hair or skin type in their
personal profile so the products will be
tailored to their needs boxes are
available for men as well as women but
if Mitch Martin da Flight Center
companies cannot offer inferior products
or samples of standard products things
that aren't exclusive for very popular
you can only make that mistake once
customers won't forgive you the staff
know I'm amana's didn't didn't feel
efforts I pelicula nisht coffeeboxx on
Berlin has been sending out surprise
packages of beauty products since 2011
it now boasts more than 250,000
subscribers in 10 countries
each of glossy boxes boxes has a theme
suited to the season or special
occasions like Valentine's Day the firm
pays particular attention to the boxes
design the wrapping and unwrapping are
all important if you have infused little
there are four steps to opening the box
you lift the lid untie the bow open or
pull out the magazine and you can see
right away with the theme is I have to
loose panel excitement builds then you
remove the little sticker and lift the
paper everything's geared toward this
momentary experience there there stop
Oscar this video bloggers are an
important factor in the success of
beauty boxes as a business model such
unboxing videos are popular and some
bloggers operate YouTube channels with
as many as half a million subscribers
companies send these women boxes for
free even if their assessments aren't
always positive
this month I'm unfortunately not so
happy says it's buttery soft like it's
melting one hit this would have cost 10
euros crazy dog food bloggers play a
really important role in the marketing
of these products many young women no
particular learn about cosmetics almost
exclusively through YouTube blocks they
watch the videos and subscribe to the
channels where they watch every episode
so it makes perfect sense for these
companies to send bloggers their
products to unpack and show off OMG i'm
also pack one on science lesson
if it alemdar also has her own blog for
which she shoots around two videos a
week
if it wants to make her viewers feel
good to give them a place where they can
forget their everyday troubles
is a communication communication and
technology which I'm really interested
in bundled together with beauty for me
it's all in one what that is and then I
also get feedback from the people
watching it's just so intimate like with
friends only online and you can always
get some advice welcome back everybody
today we're looking at GlossyBox again
to keep bloggers and customers happy the
subscription boxes need to offer
something new each month because who
doesn't like getting presents and
watching others unwrap there's can be
fun too